hello everyone welcome back to our
Channel today we have an incredibly
important topic to discuss especially in
this day and age where online threats
are constantly evolving we are diving
deep into the world of cyber security
and we will be talking about the top
cyber security tools for 2024 so whether
you are individual concerned about your
Online safety or a business looking to
protect your digital assets you are in
the right place so let's get started and
before starting if you are an aspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's deg degree with a 50%
average and no prior programming
experience and OnePlus year of work
experience is preferred for more details
you can use the link in the description
box below now let's get started with the
increasing Reliance on digital
Technologies our privacy and safety are
at risk more than ever before cyber
security tools play a vital role in
protecting us from potential online
threats so we'll start with objectives
of cyber security tools so cyber SEC
tools have various objectives and
they're designed the first is to analyze
infrastructure data to detect anomalies
and vulnerabilities and the next
objective is to automate cyber security
workflows for efficiency and then we
have build secure web-based services and
then monitor network operations and user
activities so these are the objectives
of cyber security tools now we'll see
the considerations for choosing cyber
security tools choosing the the right
cyber security tools for your specific
needs is crucial here are some key
considerations When selecting these
tools number one is scalability and show
the tool can protect many endpoints and
devices across a wide parameter and then
we have integration it should seamlessly
integrate with your existing systems and
the next consideration is opt for tools
with reliable support as cyber secur is
ever evolving and the next consideration
is purpose built look for tools designed
to address different scenarios
effectively and the next is
compatibility the tool should work with
various device variants operating
systems and Cloud vendors so these are
the considerations for choosing cyber
security tool now let's dive into the
exciting part that is the top service
security tools for 2024 so these tools
are designed to keep you safe in the
digital world so first we will start
with solar wind security event manager
the solar wind security event manager is
a powerful network monitoring platform
with real-time packet analysis
capabilities and dynamic baselines to
detect genuine performance deviations
and now we'll see the key features for
the solar wind security event manager so
the first key feature is smarter
scalability solar wind security event
manager offers scalable Solutions
suitable for large environments whether
your organization has numerous endpoints
or diverse devices spread across a white
parameter this tool can adapt and
protect your network effectively then we
have multivendor network monitoring this
feature allows you to monitor not only
your network but also a variety of
vendors ensuring that you can keep an
eye on all aspects of your digital
infrastructure this is essential in
today's interconnected and multivendor
network environments and then we have
advanced alerting system solar wind
security event manager provides an
advanced alerting system that helps you
detect and respond to security threats
swiftly by setting up customized alerts
you can proactively address potential
issues before they escalate into major
breaches and then we have monitor end to
end Network understanding the entire
network path is crucial for identifying
bottlenecks vulnerabilities and
potential threats solar winds tool
enables you to Monitor and to end
Network Parts ensuring that you have
full visibility into your network
performance and the next key feature is
cross tech network data correlation with
cross tech network data correlation you
can connect the dots between various
Network elements and pinpoint the root
cause of issues quickly this capability
is a game changer when it comes to
troubleshooting and responding to
security incidents so this was all about
the first tool that is solar wind
security event manager now moving to
second tool that is wire shock it's an
open source Network protocol analyzer
that helps professional identify network
security weaknesses by capturing and
analyzing data packets in real time now
we'll see the key features of wir shock
so the first key feature is
crossplatform compatibility wi shock is
a crossplatform tool which means it can
be installed on a variety of operating
systems making it accessible to a wide
range of users then we have open source
architecture being open source means
that wi shark is continually improved by
a global community of Developers this
openness also facilitates easy
integration with other cyber security
tools and systems and then the next
feature is realtime data capture and
Analysis v shark provides real-time
packet capture and Analysis allowing you
to monitor network activity as it
happens this feature is invaluable for
identifying anomalies security threats
and performance issues and then the next
feature is decryption protocol support
it supports decryption for multiple
Network protocols and various output
formats enabling you to understand
encrypted traffic and identify potential
security
vulnerabilities and now moving to the
next tool that is the third tool and
that is ax script so ax script premium
offers Advanced encryption features in a
userfriendly package ensuring your data
remains secure it supports various
platforms making it convenient for users
and now we'll see the key features of a
excript the number one is 256bit
encryption ax script employs strong
256bit encryption which is virtually
unbreakable with current technology this
level of encryption ensures that your
data remains secure and confidential and
the next is userfriendly interface one
of EX script standout feature is its
user friendly interface encrypting and
decrypting files is as simple as
dragging and dropping them into into the
ax script window this accessibility
makes it usable for users and all
technical levels and the next is secure
file deletion a excript goes beyond
encryption by offering secure file
deletion this feature ensures that when
you delete an encrypted file it becomes
virtually impossible to recover
providing an additional layer of data
protection and then the next feature is
gross platform compatibility a script
supports various operating systems
including Windows Mac OS Android and iOS
this versatility allows you to encrypt
and decrypt files seamlessly across
different devices and platforms and then
the next feature is user support a
script provides user support through
email forums and even second level
support while chat if you encounter any
issues or have questions about using the
tool there's a support system in place
to assist you and then the next feature
is public key cryptography a crypt
offers the option to use public key
cryptography which allows you to
securely share encrypted files with
others only those with the appropriate
decryption key can access the files
enhancing collaboration while
maintaining security so why excript
matters data protection a script is a
crucial tool for safeguarding sensitive
data whether you are an individual
protecting personal files or a business
securing confidential documents a script
ensures that your information remains
prate and now moving on to the fourth
tool that is Kali Linux Kali Linux is a
widely used cyber security tool with
over 300 utilities for scanning Network
systems it's a great for both experts
and entry-level professionals making it
versatile and effective and now moving
to key features for Cali Linux the
number one feature is versatile tool set
K Linux boast an extensive collection of
over 300 cyber security tools making it
incredible L versatile for various tasks
including network analysis vulnerability
assessment and penetration testing and
then we have userfriendly interface
despite its powerful capabilities K NX
offers a userfriendly interface making
it accessible even to those with limited
Linux experience its Manu driven
navigation simplifies and simplifies the
process of selecting and using tools and
the next is customizable Ki Linux allows
users to customize and tailor the
distribution to their specific needs
this means you can install additional
tools or remove unnecessary ones to
create streamline and efficient
environment and then we have regular
updates to stay ahead of emerging
threats and vulnerabilities Ki Linux is
continuously updated the development
team ensures that the tools within the
distribution are up to date with the
latest security patches and improvements
and then we have wide device
compatibility Ki Linux is compatible
with a wide range of hardware and can be
installed on various devices including
laptops desktops and even Raspberry Pi
devices this flexibility ensures that
you can take your cyber security toolkit
with you wherever you go and the next we
have is Community Support Ki Linux has a
vibrant and active community of users
and developers who contribute to its
growth and provide support through
forums this community aspect makes it
easier to learn and troubleshoot any
issues you may encounter now moving to
to the fifth tool that is air crack NG
air crack NG is an open- Source suit of
Wireless tools used for analyzing Wi-Fi
network security weaknesses it's a
comprehensive Solution that's entirely
free now we'll see and learn some of the
key features of air crack NG the first
feature is open source architecture air
crack NG is a open source software which
means it's freely available for anyone
to use modify and contribute to its
development this open Nature Fosters a
community of users and developers
continuously working to enhance its
capabilities and the next is
compatibility aircra NG is versatile in
terms of compatibility while it
primarily works on Linux it has also
been adapted to run on other operating
systems including Windows Mac OS free
bstd open bstd net bstd Solaris and even
Ecom Station 2 this compatibility
ensures that users from various
backgrounds and preference can harness
its power now the next feature is suit
of programs aircra NG comprises a suit
of programs each serving a specific
purpose in wireless network security
some of the notable components include
air Decap NG aerod dump NG air T NG so
these command line tools allow for
intricate scripting and customization
making air crack NG a valuable asset for
professionals seeking to fine-tune their
wireless security effort
and the next feature is Wi-Fi security
assessment aircrack NG is particularly
adapt at assessing the security of Wi-Fi
networks and the next is password
cracking one of the standout features of
air crack NGS is is its ability to crack
Wi-Fi passwords while it's essential to
use its capability responsibly and
legally the next is Community Support
airrack NG boast an active and engaged
user community so this was the features
of aircrack now moving on to the tool
six that is ncto so ncto is an excellent
open source tool focused on scanning the
web for vulnerabilities covering both
web servers and networks it's
continuously updated to help users
identify threats now moving on to see
the key features of ncto number one is
comprehensive scanning nct's database
consists of approximately 6,400 distinct
types of security threats covering both
web servers and networks it scans
websites for a wide range of
vulnerabilities including outdated
software misconfigured servers and known
security issues the next feature is web
server and network focus ncto is
specialized in scrutinizing web servers
and the networks they operate on it
doesn't just look for issues on the
surface it digs deep into the serers
configuration to identify potential
weaknesses the next is continuous
updates the tool is continuously updated
to keep Pace with emerging threats and
vulnerabilities the next is lightweight
and ver
ncto is a lightweight web application
vulnerability scanner making it easy to
use and integrate into existing security
workflows the next is plugin system ncto
plugin system allows for easy
extensibility new plugins can be created
to make it compatible with different
systems making it adaptable to a wide
variety of web server setups so how nto
Works nto operates by sending HTTP
request to the Target web server and
analyzing the responses it receives it
looks for specific patterns or
characteristics that indicate
vulnerabilities nto doesn't exploit
vulnerabilities but rather provides a
comprehensive report highlighting
potential issues allowing administrators
to take appropriate action so this was
all about the ncto tool now moving to
the seventh tool that is force point
force point is a tool used to customize
ston helping track and prevent mous
activities within networks it offers a
high level of customization and
real-time content analysis now I'm going
to see the key features of this tool the
number one is high level security Force
Point provides a high level of security
across various applications and
resources within your network the next
is seamless integration the tool
seamlessly integrates with different
network components ensuring that it
doesn't disrupt your existing
infrastructure and the next is
customization one of the standout
feature of force point is its
customization capabilities users can
tailor policies fingerprints and
classifiers to meet their specific
security requirements the next is
realtime content analysis Force Point
offers real-time content analysis and
classification this means that it can
identify and classify content flowing
through your network in real time the
next is gross portfolio intelligence
fource Point leverages cross portfolio
and third party Global share threat
intelligence networks this means that it
has access to a vast pool of thread data
making it more effective in identifying
and mitigating emerging thre
so this was all about the force Point
tool now moving on to the eighth tool
that is nessus professional tool nessus
professional is a handy vulnerability
scanner that's updated daily with new
thread data it's an essential tool for
improving Network Integrity now we'll
see the key features of this tool the
number one is remote scanning tool
nessus professional is a remote scanning
tool that excels in highspeed asset
Discovery the next is daily thread data
updates one of the standout features of
nesses professional is its commitment to
staying up to date with the everchanging
threat landscape and the next is ease of
deployment and use unlike some complex
cyber security tools ness's professional
is known for its ease of deployment and
user friendliness and the next is
support from TBL expert vulnerability
research team with ness's professional
you are not just getting a software tool
you are gaining access to the expertise
of table's vulnerability research team
this ensures that you have top note
support and access to the latest
insights into the cyber security
landscape and the next feature is gross
platform compatibility nessus
professional is compatible with various
operating systems including Mac Linux
and windows this broad compatibility
makes it accessible for a wide range of
users and organizations and this was all
for this tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts and to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
larns advaned executive program in cyber
security in collaboration with npci
should be your right choice with this
program you can transform your career in
6 months for India specific region only
this course provides a high engagement
learning experience and real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new and
more fulfilling career and now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Phillip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskilled with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors with many
companies before Z a security analyst
and architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened on
the first and if you like this session
then like share and subscribe if you
have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply loan staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here